hello everyone and welcome to the last
game will be showing from round five of
the 2020 candidates tournament
it's initiative versus Fabiana Caruana
and it's a it's a really exciting game
features two very exciting pause the
video moments which I'm sure gonna enjoy
well one more than the other but they
are quite enjoyable now before we check
out the game and here's their
head-to-head score as you all enjoy that
so much so prior to this game Caruana
and Anita Geary played a lot of
classical games
Fabiana 1-3 everyone - and 26 of the
games were drawn and if you include
classical Madrid in exhibition games
then Caruana be giving 9 to 5 with 38
draws so a slight advantage for for
Fabian in classical time format and also
let's enjoy some close-ups before we
start with the game here's a nice
close-up of Fabi so let's just enjoy
that for a second and also a very nice
photo of onigiri so let's let's check
out that that one as well so there you
have it and now let's let's see what
happens here Gary opens with d4 and Fabi
once again goes for the Slav we have c4
and c6 the Slav defense is on the board
Knight of three we have Knight to f6 and
III now preparing to develop the light
square Bishop Bishop to f5 developing
the light square bishop before closing
the cage and Knight to c3 now with east
six and now that the bishop can no
longer go back gear immediately goes
after it
Knight to h4 with Bishop the e4
f3 Bishop to g6 and now mostly played
move here is Queen to b3 wear with or
without including Knight captures and g6
first but Queen to b3 is the main idea
but here Giri goes for Bishop to b2 it's
a much rarer move and with it he hopes
to throw fob you off guard but Fabi just
continues developing Bishop to e7
now some nasty discoveries could be
possible if this Knight ever moves so
giri eliminates the bishop now the
Knight captures H captures and the Queen
to c2 now now saying that he will maybe
Castle queenside as he already made way
for the king Knight B to d7 by Fabi and
here we have castles Queen side by giri
and there
one game in the database for Queen to c7
was played but here father goes for
night to b6 and it is as I've moved 11
that we have a completely new game so
let's see let's see what happens gearing
now of course he doesn't want the
position on the Queen side to open up as
he just Castle queenside so of course
c5 who wants to close it Knight bt7 and
now king b1 a nice prophylactic move
getting a king to a safer Square and
here well you could start breaking up
this spawn chain would be six Fabi first
precursor with Queen to b8 now b6 is
definitely an option but also you are
just threatening to gobble up that pawn
on H 2 O so gear replace h4 and now g5
by Fabi as the rook is still under
undefended the bishop has been hasn't
been developed so the rooks are not
connected so Bishop back to e 1 by Gary
defending the h4 pawn twice and now even
g4 by Fabi we have E 4 by Gary striking
in the center G captures on f3 g
captures and now finally b65 he starts
opening up the position he captures on
d5 with each captors and b5 and now C
captures on b6 even that we have a
capture some basics now opening up the a
file for the rook Fabi will play
something like Quinta a 7/32 pressure da
to pawn and now Knights to 8 you
probably with the idea that he wants to
either ship this nice to see one to help
up with the defense of the a to pawn or
he may be once the once the gift maybe
to g4 to g3 and then to f5 so first
Queen to a7 by Fabi threatening just
Queen captures and now instead of going
back to Gary decides that he will use
the night so instead b3 now defending
the a to pawn and it now leaves the
Queen stuck here to guard e8 upon but at
least you can move the knight now we
have nice to h5 by Fabi and now Knights
to g3
just offering a trade hoping for
captures captures then he gets this
beautiful bishop in then the other
bishop can go to this diagonal and so on
so instead we have g6 by Fabi
Gary trades Knight captures and h5
instead of pawn rook captures on h5 and
now F
or a really strong move by Giri
preparing to kick away the roof from age
five and also start to develop those
bishops kink the f8 by Fabi getting the
King to to a safer location with idea so
maybe King g7 artificially castling
Bishop to e2 kicking the rook back and
did not work the h8 and here we reach
the first critical position of the game
feel free to pause the video here and
try to figure out what you would play
here with white but it's an incredibly
difficult task so you know don't overdo
it so for those of you who found f5 you
you you should also congratulate
yourself because it's such a such a
disgusting engine line that there is no
way anyone plays this but it's
interesting during the livestream Magnus
calls and said that he wouldn't be
surprised if White was just winning here
they couldn't really figure out why but
it doesn't seem like black has anything
to do but it's hard to find out what
white can do here so for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show
it's f5 this is the critical line but
it's it's so difficult to calculate g5
by black now of course you cannot
capture because you lose the rook here
and now Bishop to f3 first now the rook
is defended G captures on h4 and now
Bishop to g3 this is how you you gain
development and of course black cannot
capture because of rook after sin h8 so
look the h6 getting directed to help out
with the defense of the c6 pawn it's
it's not the target yet because the
Queen has to keep an eye on the ATO
point but better better safe than sorry
Bishop f4 kicks the rug back rook h7 and
now rook to h2 now the rook here defends
the pawn here now there's the threat of
capturing this and white will just have
an incredible game here for example this
Bishop can come to a 5 look and come
either to e1 maybe even to H want to
double up on the H file a lot of good
things can happen here for white but
it's it's you know hard to decide on
such a move so basically from this
position where the bishops are here and
your rooks are not coordinated well the
queen is stuck guarding the eight
one you would reach this position where
the bishops are nicely placed here the
Rope help helps out with the defense of
the point and black didn't really do
anything so basically white got five
free moves without black actually being
able to do anything so this is the the
real secret behind the position however
it's an incredibly hard to find and give
your first played Bishop to d3 now with
ideas of preparing f5 and now c5 by Fabi
we have Bishop the c3 opening up hoping
to open up this diagonal so far B does
it capture Sun b4 capture son d4 in the
bishop to f6 now Bobby seems to have
solved all of his problems but again
feel free to pause the video and try to
find the winning move for Geary while I
give you a couple of seconds so for
those of you who are able to do it you
should definitely congratulate yourself
because it's a move that both the Geary
and Caruana missed and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show
it's a shock to be 5 seems crazy that's
such a move you can take down a player
like Caruana but it is in the position
point is you're threatening the simple
tactics of Bishop captures you remove
the defender of this Bishop and then you
win a piece so black obviously has to do
something about that so Bishop captures
and d4 of course now rook captures on d4
and now after the knight moves and now
you have this f5 move just continue
attacking g5 and now rook to a four and
now you will overload the black Queen
for example if the Queen moves Queen b8
now you go Queen to be two attacking the
knight here and the rook and there's not
much you can do here for example if King
g7 defending then looked g1 is
incredibly strong threatening just
captures and you will win the win the
night here for example if you look out
for Sunday for you can just play even H
captures and g5 and now there's not much
to do here
rook rook h2 attacking the Queen then
Queen captures on f6 kink the f8 and now
of course Bishop captures an a4 and at
the end of this variation you are you
are upper piece so another thing you
could do here after Queen to beat you
instead of instead of moving
with something like ink the g-seven you
could try the route capture Sunday for
immediately but then the tuition to
Queen captures on f6 and you're still
threatening to capture this rook and the
district so you would have to go for
rook captures here
rook H captures on h4 but now again you
get rook to g1 and there's again not
much not much black can do here you
cannot move this rook anywhere from the
H file because well Queen h8 check just
picks up the Queen here and not not a
lot of things you can do the the rook is
coming in the position and that will
that will be it
so really and your rook is hanging so
you do have to do something about it
after rook moves let's say to a8 Queen
captures and g5 attacks here goes to g7
the point is coming here Bishop covers
d8 it's dead lost for black so really
exciting stuff after table is Bishop to
f6 but Giri misses it get replaced
Bishop captures an f6 instead we have
Knight captures on f6 and now f5 finally
giri breaks through G captures an f5
Bishop captures on f5 and then now b5 by
Fabi again saying ok you have a nice
position Giri but your queen is still
stuck guarding this pawn here so you
have to do something about it so he does
Giri goes rook to h2 now the Queen can
finally be activated and now rook to h5
now keeping the Queen stuck guarding the
bishop here so look the e2 by yuri and
now d4 just further pushing we have
looked a five a nice rook lift that now
defends the bishop now the Queen can
finally move but now Bobby finds Knight
to g4 now of course if you capture you
lose the rook ended the night is now
coming to e3 so here look the c5 with
the threat of rook the c8 check but Fabi
goes for 9th to e3 either way so again
what do you do here rook the ca to check
only good move for giri we have captures
captures with the check and now not King
here because of rook to g1 King the e7
instead so again what do you do here
rook the c1 you have to get the roof to
safety and now comes Knight to d5 as the
threat is just rook to c7 check to win
the Queen so nice the
d5 guarding this and now Giri goes for
rook to e1 with check Fabi again blocks
Knight to the e3 rook to C 1 we have
Knight back to d5 rook to e1 with Czech
Knights to e3 and after Luke 2 c1
it was in this position unmoved 42 that
giri and cara wanna agreed to a draw so
really a really tough game really
complicated game
Fabi had to spend a lot more time in the
opening Giri I'll prepared him but then
when it would when it was time to strike
and give he had to chance okay that f5
move not not likely for anyone to find
but that that Bishop to b5 move that
that seems to be outright winning that
that was definitely Gary's chance but
yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it here there's no real way to
look for advantage if you try something
like well what could you try let's say
Knight back to d5 threatens this we have
we have something for white maybe maybe
you try this to get rid of the defender
and then when the Queen but then just
night to check winds the winds the
bishop or or you have to give up the
exchange so not much you can do there
and for example if Bishop g4 maybe
attacking the rook try to go for the
night this way then rookie five you no
longer have any rook e1 checks and if
the bishop f3 just Knight c3 check again
just waiting for black if you move your
you're getting Queen captures on h2 and
if you if you don't then you just have
to give up the exchange with the rook
address and you're just worse so after
Luke the c1 they drew the game and here
are the standings now after five rounds
of the Vita candidates twenty20
tournament there we have it in first
place we have young upon shoot with
three and a half out of five points
after winning his game against von Kahr
followed by maxime beaugeois graphic on
a Kerwin Ivanka and locks on the
guruship with two and a half so on 50%
and then with two points Dingley ran our
key role Alex Cinco and uh nice giri so
those are the standings after five
rounds but it's a it's a long tournament
a long way to go we'll see we'll see
what happens
so really really exciting stuff and what
do you think of the tournament so far do
you agree with with the statement
Alexander Greek made in an inner
he said that he definitely thinks that
the the tournament should be either
stopped or postponed that that it's not
it's not without cause that all of the
other big events in the world have been
cancelled or postponed and that he just
doesn't feel feel right playing in the
tournament everyone were masked there's
a lot of security everywhere and it just
kills the mood of the tournament and he
says that with all that in mind being on
50% that he is very happy with his
result but he definitely thinks that the
tournament shouldn't have happened so
what are your thoughts on this and yeah
well I'll see I'll see you guys soon I
would like to think we'd be Holdings LLC
Simon Johansson Harry Willis Gleb
kochenko and Randall Ingersoll for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check too on my previous video serie
think all for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
feeder candidates tournament so thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent start of your week